[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois sauvadet bonjour je vous
remercie beaucoup d'être avec nous et
nous avons rejoint président centriste
du département de la côte d'or vous
présidez l'assemblée des départements de
france et on est enceinte pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord jean julien bonjour
rien ne bouge ambitieux ce manège
bonjour on va bien sûr parlé à des
départements dans quelques instants
françois sauvadet mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est ce conseil de défense
sanitaire nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire qui se tient ce matin avec une
question le passé ni terre doit-il être
allégée pour les départements où le
virus circule peu est ce que pour vous
il faut le départementalisée maintenant
se passait moi j'étais toujours
favorable à des mesures territorialisée
parce qu'on le voit bien il ya eu des
sujets d'incompréhension sur les mesures
de protection qui ont été prises parce
qu'elle était pas tout à fait adapté à
ce qu'on vivait les gens on a on a
traité la seine saint denis comme comme
que mon village où il y avait personne
dans les rues donc évidemment ça a
suscité de l'incompréhension
moi je crois que parce sanitaire
aujourd'hui ce que je constate c'est que
ça fonctionne donc moi je ne sont pas de
tension particulière lorsqu'on veut se
déplace au restaurant dans bon
maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est adapter
les mesures en fonction de l'évolution
pandémique par territoire et par
département ça me semble être la bonne
mais est-ce que ça doit venir ça déjà
commencé vous le savez en côte-d'or
début de semaine les jeunes ne portent
plus le masque à l'école primaire donc
on va ça va évoluer je crois que comme
un masque bien sûr c'est à dire faut
qu'on soit prudentielles aussi un il
faut éviter tout comportement qui kiprop
qui présenterait un risque pour l'avenir
mais moi je suis un fervent partisan de
la territorialisation jeux dédiés aux
bons au premier ministre il faut
impérativement qu'on discute des mesures
des modalités de mise en oeuvre des
mesures je crois que c'est ça la grande
leçon qu'il faut tirer il faut associer
les élus locaux n'ont pas simplement en
les informant des décisions mais sur la
mise en oeuvre des décisions et c'est ce
débat qui fait qu' on renforce la
crédibilité des bus est attendu ce que
vous nous dites c'est que l'état était
finalement un peu trop autoritaire dise
je le dis très simplement il ya une
forme d'arrogance sanitaire moins de
salles au tout début de la crise j'étais
prêt je suis présidente département donc
tous homos co tutelle sur les ehpad la
rs avait donné l'ordre de ne pas
m'informer sur la situation de la
pandémie dans nos plans d'eau dans nos
espaces est pas supportable donc on voit
bien qu après ça le dialogue d'ailleurs
on a remis les préfets pour dialoguer
aussi avec les élus et fait en sorte de
discuter des modalités et ça et c'est
comme ça qu'on a mieux réussi d'ailleurs
on s'est impliqué nous mêmes dans la
vaccination l'idée on s'est impliqué
dans la prise en charge dans la
livraison des masses concept un pic aux
côtés de l'état et on a mieux réussi
parce qu'on à travailler mieux ensemble
c'est je crois que c'est ça la leçon
qu'il faut tirer on gagne pas la
bataille de l'avenir sans les élus
locaux par les
ouïes actualité dramatique le rapport ce
rapport sauvé sur les abus sexuels
la pédocriminalité au sein de l'église
catholique alors jean christophe lagarde
a eu une expression sur le sur le sujet
il a dénoncé hier le caractère
systémique de ces crimes est considéré
que cela devait poser la question à
l'église catholique du mariage de cm2
ses prêtres qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire et moi je crois que vous savez
nous sommes en charge départements de
france de la protection de l'enfance je
crois que c'est le sujet le plus
lancinant qu'on a eu et il faut d'abord
libérer la parole il faut vraiment que
on ne cache pas des situations de
violence faite à des enfants et je crois
que ce rapport il est utile d'abord pour
adresser un signal c'est nous sommes
tous co-responsables la protection de
nos enfants et de cadets qu'on a un fait
porté connaissance d'un fait délictueux
ou criminel d'atteintes sexuelles ou
date un enfant on a la responsabilité de
faire savoir du sérielle saisir ça va
dit remettre en cause le secret de la
confession mais écoutez moi je le pense
profondément
bon on peut pas rester dans la situation
à terre des crimes qui sont commis sur
des enfants c'est une responsabilité
collective et moi d'ailleurs j'ai invité
dans mon département tous les élus
locaux les associations
dès qu'il ya un soupçon de maltraitance
enfants et de crimes sexuels tout
particulièrement de s'engager et de le
dire c'est pas de la délation c'est
qu'il faut protéger nos enfants vous
rendez compte pour une vie qui commence
l'adulte qui doit être leur père
qui donne le chemin et c'est celui qui
viole qui bat et bien je dois vous dire
que nous avons une responsabilité
individuelle par rapport à ces
événements il responsable collective en
tout cas c'est probablement un sujet des
plus lancinant et moi je suis je suis
satisfait de cet effort de transparence
qui a été fait parce que c'est une
sensibilisation de toute l'opinion alors
c'est cet effort il a été faussée
l'église cet effort de transparence et
ce travail est ce que maintenant il doit
être fait dans d'autres institutions
partout et rejeté de fait c'est même pas
dans des institutions mais ça renvoie la
responsabilité individuelle je vous
répète chaque fois qu'il ya un cas où on
a soupçons de maltraitance il faut
absolument de saisir et nous mêmes
d'ailleurs nous nous faisons en sorte
que très tôt dès qu'on a le et l'école
aussi qu est un lieu où tous nos enfants
vont et on travaille beaucoup et
l'éducation nationale donc c'est une
responsabilité individuelle et
collective nous devons protéger nos
enfants
surtout dans un monde qui est devenu
difficile où il ya de la montée de la
précarité et donc la prévention du
risque social intervenir le plus tôt
possible dès qu'on a dû porter à
connaissance libérer la parole je crois
que c'est essentiel pour pour faire face
à ce à ce drame absolu et puis en plus
moi je pense aux victimes je crois que
c'était nécessaire aussi de pour elle de
dire l'ampleur du phénomène je crois que
c'est une prise de conscience collective
que ça doit permettre
la tête de la france au coeur quel sera
la marque sauvadet
écoutez la marque sauvadet je suis pas
sûre et de marx ou wallemme il y aura
deux marques des départements de france
non je crois qu on est convenus d'abord
qu'il faut rester ferme sur les
principes moi je vous le dit les
départements ne sont pas les sous
traitants de l'état quand je vois des
injonctions quand je vois que encore
récemment sur l'aide à domicile on nous
fixe à prix plancher à prendre dit on va
discuter ensemble du prix convient de
fixer il peut pas y avoir de décisions
prises sans qu'elles soient
préalablement discutée dans les
compétences qui nous sont transférées et
j'observe que là on a une
renationalisation donc la marque elle
est très simple ça va être ferme sur les
principes pour rappeler que si on veut
réussir la bataille de l'avenir il faut
travailler avec ceux qui sont les
acteurs locaux travailler ensemble et à
et acteurs locaux et puis la marque
aussi c'est de définir ensemble les
modalités mais en tout cas nous avons un
vrai travail je m'en suis expliqué que
le premier ministre
ce qui vous a répondu sur le sujet il a
compris que cette 7,7 ces critiques mais
je crois qu'il a il a entendu que on
peut pas continuer à nous imposer des
mesures on a quand même traversé des
périodes difficiles à la suppression du
foncier bâti on n'a plus de marge de
manoeuvre financière on est d'ailleurs
dans une situation très fragile
aujourd'hui les droits de mutation
marche bien donc on a eu la ressource
mais dans certains départements ça reste
encore limitée monde est en situation
fragile si si demain on se retrouve face
à une crise comme en 2008 avec une chute
des droits de mutation tour des
départements de france vont se retrouver
en faillite il ya plus d'amortisseur
dont je trouve qu'il faut qu'on ait une
réflexion prospective
alors il ya des textes qui sont
aujourd'hui sur devant nous on a
plusieurs textes à les lois dites de
décentralisation montferrat 3ds qui soit
qui est une loi d'ajustement technique
donc moi j'ai proposé au premier
ministre que l'artois let et qu'on
enlève les irritants vous aviez vous
aviez parlé de coproduction mais on
al'impression finalement cette
opposition n'a pas lieu c'est pas une
coproduction je crois que le
gouvernement se livre à des arbitrages
qui ne sont pas très satisfaisant j'ai
lu de lui dit d'ailleurs premier
ministre oncle dialogue se poursuive pas
les irritants pages prend un exemple
elle est là la route nationale
transférer des routes nationales proposé
de transfert de route nationale à des
régions qui n'ont aucune compétence donc
un savoir faire dans ce domaine alors
que nous sommes responsables des trois
cent soixante quinze mille kilomètres de
voirie départementale dans notre pays
saâd annonce ans donc j'ai dix proposées
dès d'abord au département quand même
parce que comment voulez vous que ça
fonctionne les gestionnaires de collèges
imagineront on est tous en train
d'essayer de renforcer l'alimentation de
proximité
les produits bio dans nos collèges on
n'a pas la main sur les gestionnaires
donc moi j'ai proposé le transfert des
gestionnaires on me dit ah ça c'est pas
possible parce que monsieur blanca ne
veut pas enfin attendez est-ce qu'on a
peur de voir quelques gestionnaires dans
la rue qui vont se fâcher parce que tout
simplement nous payons l'entretien nous
payons les cantines etc et on n'a pas la
main sur celui qui gère l'argent face la
vraisemblable médecine scolaire pareil
jeudi mais il coûtait faisons un état
des lieux de la médecine scolaire elle
était où la médecine scolaire pour la
vaccination de nos jeunes c'est l'été où
cette reprise en main monsieur sauvadet
est ce que c'est le mot d'ordre que vous
allez prononcer lors des prochaines
assises alors début décembre comment
vous allez cette maman d'ordre j'en ai
discuté de la stratégie il ya encore en
bureau avec l'ensemble des départements
de france la stratégie est claire ferme
sur les principes on ne décide pas sur
nos compétences à notre place ça c'est
l'esprit même de la décentralisation qui
a été remis par fois en cause et
deuxièmement on travaille sur les
modalités à mettre en oeuvre et efficace
c'est la crise qu'on traverse c'est
c'est une crise de l'action publique
tout s'est complexifiée tout le monde de
faire tout et son contraire il faut
redonner du sens et redonner une
capacité à agir moi ce que j'observe
tout simplement c'est que le département
est devenu est redevenu le bon espace de
l'action d'ailleurs le gouvernement
lui-même ne s'y trompe pas puisqu'il est
en train de déconcentrer en renforçant
l'échelon départemental
il faut que ce renforcement de l'état
départementale ne soit pas une mise sous
tutelle des élus locaux nous sommes des
responsables politiques nous sommes élus
nous avons des compétences nous voulons
les assumer janvier ste n'a rien d autre
à côté je trouve qu'il ya une volonté de
dialogue donc on va l'explorer en même
temps compter sur moi et je le dis à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes pour
faire en sorte que ça marche mieux ils
se sont un peu plus la
semaine dernière au début de leur
congrès à montpellier parler aussi d'une
volonté dialogue elle était beaucoup
moins la fin on parler d'humiliation
après le discours de jean castex est ce
que vous êtes inquiet vous aussi là
dessus non mais je suis pas inquiet un
responsable politique n'est pas inquiet
il est là dans ce monde anxiogène est là
pour assurer fixer un cap bon moi ce que
je vais faire aussi je vais discuter
avec les régions parce qu'il faut qu'on
se met au clair on a territoire unis
c'est à dire on s'est tous retrouvés
pour dire au gouvernement ça suffit peut
pas continuer de mépriser les élus
locaux mais une fois qu'on a dit ça faut
qu'on se mette d'accord entre nous les
régions revendique la santé eh bien
écoutez la santé le médico social ce
sont des départements peut-être qu'on se
met au clair aussi entre nous pour ne
pas laisser le gouvernement jouer lé
rôle d'arbitré dans la distribution des
compétences donc on a qu'on va commencer
dès la semaine prochaine ce travail puis
moi je vais mettre en mouvement tous les
départements de france comment
comptez-vous mettre en mouvement d'avoir
écouté ça va être très simple nous
allons diagnostic est d'abord la
situation du pays il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements il ya une aspiration
est beaucoup plus efficace il qu'on
travaille avec les élus locaux c'est ce
que nous allons faire dans chaque
département j'ai demandé à chaque
département de tenir une session dans
lequel avec les élus locaux nous allons
dire comment nous pensons que ça
pourrait mieux marcher dans notre pays
et que en sorte de cette crise où plus
personne où plus personne ne s'y
retrouve et même parfois pas même les
élus locaux donc ce travail on va le
faire je proposerai qu'on fasse sens des
propositions pour l'avenir de notre pays
je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on se
projette sur les futurs défis la
pandémie a provoqué des nouveaux
comportements sociologique nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec on parle d'un exode
urbain est il tenable est il durable
l'arrivée du numérique quel service
public avec le numérique quel proximité
le changement climatique ses
conséquences donc tout cela nous allons
nous projeter dans le futur on fera donc
une proposition sans de propositions
émanant de tout le terrain tous les
conseillers départementaux mots se met
en mouvement et seront tous invités
parce que je
les assiste dans la d'alors d'ailleurs
si on a choisi l'un c'est parce que nous
voulons retrouver un rôle premier dans
la république de centraliser que nous
appelons de nos bilans
et est ce que le problème des ministres
sera invité j'imagine j'invitais de
président de la république le président
de la république de corée m oui
salariale et je vais il n'a pas encore
répondu donc j'espère qu'il viendra
parce qu'il faut qu'il entende la voix
des territoires et donc on sera pas un
club de président des présidents qui
donnerait le sentiment
pour les pour l'exécutif et à kehl
accueilli doivent s'attendre écoutez
s'attendre à un accueil très républicain
moi je suis pour le dialogue on n'est
pas contre l'état simplement il faut que
l'état comprenne qu'on ne viendra pas
l'avenir sans impliquer les élus locaux
les élus de terrain parce que j'ai osé
dire ça n'a pas plus que je connais
mieux le département de la côte d'or que
certains hauts fonctionnaires parisiens
et c'est la vérité dernière question
concernant les départements le premier
ministre a lancé il ya quelques jours
l'expérimentation sur la
renationalisation du rsa en 500 mener
est ce que vous êtes favorable pour
d'autres départements écoutez moi je
suis pas favorable à la généralisation
je sais qu'un problème mention entretenu
avec le président de cette manie qui
devenait insurmontable
derrière tout ça c'est que l'état nous
décident des augmentations du rsa décide
des augmentations etc
ne les finance pas aujourd'hui l'état
doit au département 10 milliards d'euros
se dire qu'il décide est derrière sur
les départements qui payent donc l'anac
sont en difficulté il ya départements
urbains il ya aussi des départements
ruraux qui sont en difficulté donc c'est
la question de la solidarité nationale
le gouvernement ne pourra pas censé être
nous renvoyer à la solidarité d'entre
nous entre départements présumé riche
département président présumé pauvres
sans régler le problème du financement
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité
je pense que ça répond à une
problématique singulière d'un
département qui était étranglée et je
pense que de distinguer la prestation le
droit avec le devoir c'est pas une bonne
chose et donc nous connaissons nos
publics donc je souhaite pas la
généralisation mais c'est la position de
l'adf la généralisation de la
renationalisation des politiques
c'est comme quand nous nous parlait de
la politique de l'enfance avec des des
mises en cause des départements est ce
qu'on veut le retour des das pas
franchement des directions
départementales d'action sanitaire et
sociale sûrement pas des l'autre
question c'est la justice administrative
qui a condamné l'état à verser 1,2
million d'euros au conseil départemental
du puy-de-dôme qui lui réclamait le
remboursement des frais d'hébergement
d'urgence des familles qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de cette décision est ce
que vous encourager d'autres
départements engagés l'hébergement
d'urgence serait sous les sdf etc donc
ça c'est la responsabilité de l'état ça
rappelle aussi à l'état qu'il faut qu'il
assume sa responsabilité peut pas
simplement désigné
les collectivités koech locales comme
étant les responsables de situation
difficile on a beaucoup parlé de la
protection de l'enfance mais la
psychiatrie elle est aujourd'hui les
efforts en matière de pédopsychiatrie le
nombre de places qu'il faudrait avoir
pour soutenir les tous ces jeunes qui
sont en situation de très grande
fragilité qui relève de la santé l'état
moi je suis pour un état de droit qui
soit beaucoup plus lisible les
collectivités ont leurs compétences et
leurs responsables et doivent les
assumer l'état ne peut pas s'exonérer
des siennes et renvoyer une forme d'
incurie des pouvoirs locaux voilà de
cette
démarche est très bien s'il ya eu des
financements
d'hébergement d'urgence fait par les
départements ça fait jurisprudence
oui même si on est on parle depuis le
début mais finalement mais sait on va
parler surtout
sondage et présidentielles puisque un
nouveau sondage harris interactive pour
challenges place pour la première fois
le polémiste eric zemmour au second tour
je voulais savoir ce que ça vous inspire
écoutez l'eczéma ou d'abord il est poids
candidats savent et il est extrêmement
médiatisé moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils
aient moore s'est décéléré gilet jaune
de la politique c'est des personnes qui
en ont marre et qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent que ça change il voit surgir un
trublion un polémiste voilà bon la
tentation du clown excusez moi je
reprends un titre non non je ne dirais
pas non non moi je suis respectueux des
idées je crois que tous ceux qui veulent
participer aux débats publics doivent
être respectées je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec la vision d'eric zemmour
vous savez mais je respecte
d'intrusion dans dans la diffusion dans
la vie politique il ya un désespoir des
gens parce qu'ils ne voient pas de sens
et non pas le sentiment qu en allant
voter ça change des choses dès qu'ils
entendent quelqu'un qui pose des grands
des grandes théories de grand
remplacement qui surf un peu sur les sur
les sur les peurs finalement de l'avenir
des gens bien évidemment il ya un effet
en effet normalement puis médiatiquement
ça intéresse donc voilà ma près est-ce
que ça va être un phénomène durable et
nabeul quand on va rentrer dans le vif
du sujet risa sauf qu'une autre affaire
croyait la bulle la bulle sondagière
comme tel et chevènement jean-pierre
chauvet javel et ma manière très
générale je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
gouverner des sondages et les sondages
sont le reflet de l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui les gens se désespère donc
il faut absolument redonner du sens à la
vie politique à la présidentielle c'est
pas simplement un homme providentiel la
présidentielle c'est aussi avoir une
vision de l'avenir de notre pays et de
son meilleur fonctionnement dans un
monde qui est anxiogène et moi
j'inviterai tous les candidats à la
présidence de la république y compris le
président sortant à bâtir un programme
avec les acteurs du territoire eux-mêmes
et ne pas simplement a considéré qu' on
est l'homme providentiel l'homme
providentiel est encore à construire
vous parliez de retrouver du sens mais
en l'occurrence ça va parler de la
droite et du
delà de ce non sens qui existe à l'heure
actuelle pour retrouver un candidat un
candidat qui devait être normalement un
candidat de la droite et du centre sauf
que lui dei a été exclu du vote pour la
congrès
des républicains qui doit départager les
candidats donc qu'est-ce qui reste
encore un candidat de la droite et du
centre ah bah j'ai l'impression qu'il
reste même trop puisque ils sont
plusieurs à ils prêts à prétendre être
ce candidat dans un maul moi j'ai je
suis encore représentés même s'il écoute
et moi je pense que je veux que vous
sentez respecter en l'occurrence par
l'hérédité mais moi je ne me situe pas
sur ce registre je pense que j'appelle
chacun à la responsabilité
chacun chacun des candidats à la
présidence de la république doit définir
un projet et doit le présenter
clairement et ensuite il appartient aux
partis politiques de se déterminer et
beaucoup plus largement aux français de
se déterminer sur le choix qu'ils auront
à faire pour vous c'est un problème
d'avoir été exclus du choix du candidat
de la droite et du centre écoutez je
pense que des parties doivent réfléchir
aussi au rôle qu'ils jouent dans la vie
politique française aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'il ya un rejet des partis
traditionnels on voit bien qu'il ya même
une pratique politique qu'il faudrait
réviser je crois qu'il faut que les
partis soient beaucoup plus ouvert au
rejet sentiment que ça vaut d'ailleurs
pour tous les partis qui se replie sur
leur pré carré est ce qu'au moment où il
ya autant de doutes sur l'avenir de la
sur l'avenir d'un pays est ce que le
repli sur son pré carré purent se
choisira destin c'est la bonne méthode
pour se voir à la revue justement ce
serait ce qui en avait bien parti
socialiste voyez chez des élèves d'un
gouvernail on a cru comprendre qu'il y
ait existé même au sein dudit une
réflexion sur le sur une candidature
propre au parti vous soutenez ou est ce
que vous dites attendez c'est pas le
moment pour faire 2 %
bon écoutez je ne me prononcerai pas
comme président de l'adf comme sur les
candidatures je souhaite que les
candidats se prononcent sur ce que nous
voudrons est ce que nous proposerons
pour l'avenir 2
10 n'est pas en ne peut pas peser de
manière autonome sur cette présidence
est pas l'impression qu'aujourd'hui la
situation politique permet à un parti
politique que ce soit lui d idées l air
le parti socialiste de pouvoir est en
situation
voilà donc y en a pas un
il ne vous a pas échappé samedi edouard
philippe ex premier ministre maire du
havre créé son parti et déjà on entend
les bruits de certains mêmes élus d ea
qui est bien semble séduit au point
d'évoquer même un ralliement est ce que
vous n'avez pas peur qu ils siphonnent
les troupes de laurent blanc est d'abord
edouard philippe d'un moment il m'a pas
des saints souvenir ému si dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions franchement
sur des débats aussi simple que même les
80 kilomètres à vous souvenez c'est
enfin franchement c'est une vision quand
même assez assez central de pouvoir donc
il faut que le four discute avec lui sur
quelques l addition de son pays mais
j'ai l'impression qu'ils jouent le coup
d'après il joue 2027 ça que voulait dire
j'ai l'impression merci mots combien
c'est françois sauvadet d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin
[Musique]